john what's up buddy what do you got for
us tonight hey rich oh man this is crazy
you're like uh
someone i i who's really helped me so
much uh
throughout my life i i was going through
deep depression at one point read your
book
and man at that point
i was kind of fat out of shape
and like honestly on the verge of
killing myself read your book and
man just changed everything got into jiu
jitsu
got a full-time job making close to six
figures now in a much better place so i
just want to start off by saying thank
you so much thank you man i appreciate
that i want to get emotional i've been
following you for a while now but um
yeah so right now i'm kind of uh
struggling with a
uh with this question which is um
how do how do i kind of split my time
between
kind of
uh between work you know building
um my professional life but also at the
same time
not neglecting um
you know relationships with women and
stuff like that i've tried a bunch of
different things um
but i i kind of keep coming to like the
same issue where it's when i kind of go
out on the weekends i'll like try to set
a time uh like one day out of the week
just go out with my buddies have a great
time but we always stay out like super
late we come back it ruins my sleep
schedule for the next day and then i
just kind of hold him off
um well i mean you've read all my stuff
and watched all my content so i'm really
not going to tell you anything new so
why don't i hand it off to josh because
he's the guy that you know spins 14
plates and you know you can
you can you know bring in on the work
life balance sort of thing you know
beyond the stuff that i've talked about
yeah that was that was pretty wild
because yeah the most place i ever had
in my entire life and i was making more
money than i ever made at that point
which is yeah um all right so how did
you do it man dispense the wisdom they
go hand-in-hand
they sometimes do go hand in hand but
really it just kind of comes down to
right setting up a little bit of a
schedule for yourself right where it's
like hey you know i understand right if
i go out we're going to be out a little
bit too late there's nothing wrong with
like saying hey instead of like one day
of fun let me have like two days of fun
or like two and a half kind of days of
fun and scheduling that in there um
because you can always right find
something to do find more work to do but
for me i actually find that i'm like a
kind of a work hard play harder kind of
guy so for me it's like for you know
i'll put my nose to the grindstone and
like work on you know work my projects
everything i need to get done over the
course of like six days but then i'll go
out you know like maybe four or five
times a week sometimes six times a week
right which is can be a little bit crazy
but it's also i can look back and say i
never regret the the fun that i have
going out with uh my good friends and
with like the random adventures or the
stories that we've had so you know as
long as it's not to that point where
it's like man i really regret like
having gone out because i you know
wasted a bunch of time or anything um
you know keeping that balance in there
where you can say hey you know what i
can have a little bit of um extra fun in
there for myself because you kind of do
need that that balance in there right um
and a mentor of mine he was worth a 105
million dollars at the time when he told
me this he said hey
if i were to do my whole thing over
again i would have had a lot more fun
and enjoyed the process a lot more
because even though i have a crazy
amount of money i can't buy that time
back and yes i use like i'd rather have
you know like 80 million dollars and
like would have had more fun at that
time then you know have the 100 whatever
million dollars and you know missed out
on some feel i missed out on some stuff
so again you know just kind of try and
schedule a little bit of time for
yourself and again if you right sleep in
a little bit extra one day right as long
as you're not like you know late to work
or something like that like impacting
your actual professional life then hey
it's it's okay to go out and have a
little bit of fun you know
definitely thank you i i think for me
like what it impacts the most
is um
like my workout schedule
and yeah like as i've started to go out
uh again and go out more
that that's kind of been the thing
that's been throwing off and and
to be honest when i when i when i
realized is when i don't like when that
isn't in order when that workout
schedule isn't in order it starts
affecting like
a lot of other things around it yeah so
i mean jiren's a former fat guy too so
maybe he should chime in on that because
i mean you can get obsessed with um you
know working out right
yeah i had to get to the point where
being a former fat guy um and i always i
would say i'm off show and rich with you
two in private that a lot of times your
game gets ahead of you so like like this
weekend i had a surprise where i'm like
oh my god like this is the girl that
would have been the girl my dreams back
my beta days and not only
am i out with her she's into me like
she's really into me and she's acting
right and like cool like keep it cool
but that fat kid syndrome always sticks
with you and
there is a propensity to spend too much
time in the gym and
guys that are hard gainers have the same
issue too i was telling i was telling
her my cleaning lady has asked me for
diet advice earlier and she's like oh
you know people like you and the girls
you date because you know the clinton
lady sees you know sees what i do
obviously and uh and she's like she's
like hey can you give like give me a
seize traffic
yeah she's like can you see me like girl
fitness advice and i tell her to be
honest the people you see like like your
fitness models this ideal you set up for
yourself they're all insecure to a
degree so eventually i had to get to the
point where i'm like you know what i
like where i'm at i don't really have to
do anything else i'm already strong you
know i've got good muscle mass and good
shape you know i almost have that i
almost have that b taper i still have
some loose skin from the weight loss but
like kind of rich kind of like you with
your scars i accepted like those are my
battle wounds it's a part of my story
i normally have a six pack there's a
little flabby skin it's you know i'll
tell the story i used to weigh an extra
100 pounds now i'm in my mid-30s and you
know i feel better than most 20 year
olds do so
so accept that part of yourself live
with it move on and then now i'm at the
point where i'm just in maintenance mode
it's just don't get fat again and
there's not anxiety around it because
there is anxiety around that don't get
fat against it
so i had to reframe that in my head to
say like okay i want to age gracefully
and i want to
focus on overall well-being and when you
make those two your primary focuses you
kind of get rid of some of that anxiety
around like don't get fat don't get fat
don't get fat or am i as jacked as that
guy or oh no i should put more weight on
the bar because that guy's smaller maybe
he's lifting more but yeah i'm like you
know i'm cutting so i can't lift that
much anymore i'm gonna injure myself so
get rid of all that bs in your hedge
like no like my goal is to age
gracefully and just optimize overall
well-being and that spills over into
every area of your life including game
finances energy sleep all that good
stuff and if you have that um routine
right that's keeping you disciplined
okay great you know it's good to have
that discipline right because when you
get undisciplined that's where
everything starts going like to the
wayside so you know if the partying
right is suddenly like cutting into you
getting disciplined then that's where
you can say okay now it's time for me to
like kind of scale back the partying or
at least be like hey i'm out with my
guys instead of saying hey i'm going to
stay out until you know two three
o'clock in the morning all right guys
hey it's one o'clock i gotta bounce out
right be a little bit disciplined around
that so yeah you aren't just your
routine john john
i'd work on a i'd work on growing a
mullet and telling people your name was
john rambo
yeah you've got a monkey
project
you know get a combat jacket and all
that last blood
all right man good advice thank you
uh let's see what andy's got for us he's
uh he's been waiting patiently rich i'll
tell you real quick too as far as
partying you don't have to go out and
get drunk every night too like i was
telling you guys in the private chat
like a lot of times when i go out i have
a really nice social
plant medicine that's delivered via a
pen that's more on the upper side but it
really just kind of cuts through social
anxiety and just puts you like in a real
chill like all right i can vibe up this
stage
that and or maybe like micro does a
little bit of another fungi type of
plant medicine figure it out but like
you don't really have to drink like if
you go and if you show up already on a
good vibe then you can order like diet
sodas or like guys in nashville miami
have seen me i bring like these
sugar-free gatorade packets and i just
mix those into like sparkling water or
something sip on it all night if i want
to have something to drink and there's a
bottle at the table maybe i'll pour a
bit into it but normally you don't need
to drink and if you don't do that you
can still stay out all night but you're
not hungover the next day like maybe
you're a little groggy because your
sleep schedule's off but like you don't
have those physical ailments that you
know rejecting poison which is what
alcohol is from your system so a couple
of tidbits there that's a good point hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you